john ils seront près de 300 à avoir
répondu à l'appel
celui d'une mobilisation déclarée en
préfecture on vous dira tout rue tu vas
pas entendre ma gauche on va à droite
vous aimez le dit dans le cortège
l'ambiance se veut bon enfant ce
mercredi après midi
certaines familles profitent de leur
temps libre pour descendre dans la rue
c'est la première fois que je manifeste
heures depuis le début du mouvement
parce que je pense que c'est important
les fins de mois sont difficiles pour
tout le monde pour l'avenir de mes
enfants aussi oublié les images de
débordements ils s'agitent aujourd'hui
dû remettre les revendications aux
produits points et gilles et gmc les
gens qui arrivent pas à finir leurs fins
de mois qui sont dehors qui sont
assommés de taxes et qui n'en peuvent
plus c'est sale et chez les jaunes oui
on n'est pas un parti politique n'est
pas un syndicat
on sait pas exactement comment faire on
n'est pas organisée mais on n'est pas ni
des casseurs ni des gens qui réclament
tout et n'importe quoi on veut
simplement vivre normalement de notre
salaire c'est tout ce qu'on demande
trois semaines après avoir émergé le
mouvement est il en passe de se
structurer pour l'instant pas question
de parler de partis politiques
ici on veut surtout faire entendre sa
voix on veut pas de quartier
ceux qui veulent les syndicats qui
veulent venir avec nous on les accepte
mais par contre on veut pas leur gilet
on veut des gilet jaune sur le dos et on
veut pas de leurs revendications ou leur
pub pour certains ça fait 60 ans qu'ils
écoutent 50 ans 30 ans 20 en disant
qu'on écoute les gens maintenant ne les
écoute plus ceux qui vont venir nous
écouter ça fonctionne on a eu deux
sénatrices qui sont venus une
conseillère régionale des institutions
le maire etc
les gens vont venir écouter ce qu'ont à
dire et vont le porter une marche est à
nouveau prévue mercredi prochain dans
les rues de chalon
elle ne devrait cette fois pas être
déclarée en préfecture